nous sommes dans les montagnes au nord
de téhéran
un petit paradis de fraîcheur loin du ko
automobile et des tensions politiques
c'est ici que les familles et une partie
de la jeunesse iranienne qui viennent se
détendre une zone de tolérance une
certaine jeune femme aux enlever leur
voile obligatoire en république
islamique
ici on prend des elfes et on fume le
narguilé
on déjeune au milieu de la rivière
[Musique]
beaucoup de ces jeunes n'ont pas voté à
l'élection
j'aime bien
nous allons voir à considérer que le
scrutin était joué d'avancé verrouillé
de manière à garantir une victoire
facile au candidat ultraconservateur
ebrahim raïssi un proche du guide
suprême l'ayatollah ali khamenei
pour eux la question qui se pose
désormais est de savoir si maintenant
que les ultra conservateurs sont
parvenus au pouvoir ils vont continuer à
autoriser ce type d' espace de tolérance
en iran
hypothèse il
[Musique]
cette année
ah non
lord
quant aux restaurateurs et autres
professionnels du tourisme qu'ils aient
voté pour ebrahim raïssi pour le
candidat modéré ou qu'il se soit
abstenue tous rappellent à l'unisson que
l'iran est un pays accueillant d'une
grande richesse culturelle et qu'ils
attendent avec impatience la levée des
sanctions internationales et le retour
avec la sève du projet